warning you may never snack again after
watching this video
i'm going to tell you why
snacking is a very interesting and
important topic to talk about
um why do people snack well they want to
prevent overeating right
they snacked for appetite control but
what's really interesting about that is
the snacking increases insulin which
triggers hunger
about an hour and a half to two hours
later so snacking increases appetite and
encourages
overeating
now why do people snack is it always
because they're hungry
maybe because they're craving
maybe but people snack for different
reasons
stress
depression
anxiety
for social reasons because other people
are doing it they're at some social
activity
sometimes people eat just because it's
there it's available
and sometimes people snack because of
previous foods that they ate maybe
earlier in the day or the night before
which is creating a craving for example
i used to be addicted to doritos okay if
i ate doritos i could not just eat one i
ate the whole bag and then the next day
i wanted doritos the same thing when i
got into this whole ben and jerry
addiction where i was consuming a pint
of ben and jerry every night before bed
i couldn't wait till the next day until
i had that ice cream
so i have a question for you what is
worse
snacking
or
a high carb
diet now when i'm talking about these
two different
factors
i'm talking about if you're on a high
carb diet and you're not snacking
versus just snacking in general well i
believe if you compare these two factors
snacking is worse than a high carb diet
now when i weighed 211 pounds some years
ago
my face was round i had a lot of blood
sugar issues and
i was eating pretty good
but i was consuming an apple with peanut
butter uh mid morning and mid afternoon
and that was the only thing that i then
changed okay i cut out that snack
and i dropped down to 180 pounds and i'm
still convinced that it was the snacking
that was creating the problem
so i think it would be a very good
experiment if you're new to my channel
and you snack
just to try this one experiment
don't change any of the foods that
you're eating just push those foods to
the meal and have just three meals a day
but nothing in between and just see what
happens but my theory is that snacking
is worse than a high carb diet now of
course i recommend a low carb diet and
no snacking but i think that if you
compare these two factors this is worse
there is an interesting study i will
post it down below
that concluded that snacking is the only
independent factor that contributes to
weight gain in children
and at first i was thinking about well
you know it's probably the amount of
junk food they eat and things like that
but the more that i looked at that
the snacking
variable made more sense
especially since growing up in the 70s
i remember all of us consuming a
tremendous amount of junk food
but
we definitely did not snack as much as
people do now but snacking definitely
started increasing in 1977 and it
gradually increased through the 80s and
the 90s
to the point where we are now where
about 97 of children
are snacking now but at least in the
early 70s people did not snack as much
we had three meals a day and we did not
nearly have the obesity that we have
now now there are really two main ways
that you stimulate insulin there's
actually three but we're going to just
talk about two one is eating a high carb
diet number two is
eating eating in general triggers
insulin okay so it's high carbs
and eating and i'm just going to put
snacking just because if you're eating
three meals and adding two snacks you're
really creating this repetitive frequent
spike in insulin all day long
and you don't give your pancreas a
chance to
come down and reset it would be like
exercising
six times a day versus you know a few
times a day or even one time a day so
anything that triggers insulin too much
eventually creates insulin resistance
okay
insulin resistance is a state where
you have
a lot more
insulin being pumped out by the pancreas
but it's not being received okay on the
receptor end so we have certain parts of
our body
that are low on insulin but other parts
of our body that have way too much
insulin so with someone with insulin
resistance if they ever uh tested
insulin itself they would probably find
they have too much insulin in the blood
that's called hyper insulin anemia and
so when you have insulin resistance
you usually have too much insulin unless
you're a diabetic for a period of time
and the pancreas gets burned out and
then the insulin starts going down down
down now normally insulin inhibits
the formation of your liver making
uh sugar okay that's called
gluconeogenesis so when you have insulin
that goes up okay your liver stops
making this new insulin right so you can
eat sugar from your diet and have a high
blood sugar or your liver can actually
make insulin out of non-carbohydrate
sources like from protein or fat or even
ketones and then your liver can start
making insulin even though
you're not consuming any sugar okay and
so the question is
how can you have too much insulin in the
blood and still have a high level
of this liver making new sugar well
that's because you have insulin
resistance okay it's not working so the
feedback loops tell the pancreas we're
not receiving the signal pump out more
and more insulin okay
so for those people who have insulin
resistance which
i really think it's the majority of the
population
they have an increased gluconeogenesis
so the liver is just pumping a lot of
sugar this explains too why you go on a
ketogenic diet and your blood sugar is
still high you're on a low carb diet but
in the morning your blood sugar is too
high like what is up with that well
that's just because you have insulin
resistance okay so let me just quickly
go through the things that occur when
you have too much insulin in your body
it affects your cognitive function your
memory starts to go downhill you get
brain fog you lose focus your mood is
altered you start getting depressed
anxiety
irritable
it increases your cancer risk by
two times okay so it doubles your cancer
risk you gain weight especially in the
midsection your visceral area
it increases your risk of getting
cardiovascular disease and stroke and
diabetes and high blood pressure and
pcos
your muscles become weak your appetite
increases okay so
eating makes you hungry like i said
before about an hour and a half later uh
you start developing amyloid plaquing in
your brain which is kind of a precursor
for for alzheimer's you definitely get a
fatty liver your vision becomes altered
where you can't see as well
kidney issues and neuropathy which is
problems with your nerves on the bottom
of your feet there are two foods that
don't trigger insulin we know that carbs
will do it we know that an excessive
amount of protein will increase insulin
but the two foods that don't trigger
insulin are fat
and fiber okay and i'm not talking about
all the new synthetic fibers that
they're putting in all these keto treats
i'm talking about fiber from vegetables
i'm not talking about the fiber from
grains which basically have a lot of
carbohydrate in them i'm talking about
the fibrous leafy greens okay so this is
what i'm going to recommend from this
video okay so obviously you want to stop
snacking
as a first action maybe you push your
snack
to the meal as a dessert okay just do
that i promise that will you'll do
better okay you'll at least
go in the right direction
and then the step two would be starting
to go on a low carb diet which will
lower insulin and decrease the
impulse
to
snack
number two start increasing the fat in
your diet especially at the end of the
meal to help your body become more
satisfied so you can fast longer and
avoid the snacking trying to handle the
snacking issue on a low-fat diet is very
very difficult but remember fat won't
trigger insulin so it can help you
with this insulin resistance
all right number three start increasing
the fiber in your diet i'm not talking
about some added fiber that you would
add to a meal that is not part of food
i'm talking about
vegetable fibers okay like start
consuming more salads if you consume the
salad before a meal that actually can
buffer the insulin response
because it buffers the carbohydrates the
glycemic index
so you can also add the fat to the fiber
okay so let me show you
in this next slide right here
let's say you have a salad with olive
oil this is a very good combination to
help correct the insulin resistance or
celery with peanut butter as the thing
you do right after the meal
that can help you with insulin
resistance celery is actually
mostly water and fiber with virtually no
sugar and then you add the nut butter to
that
whole cream
and berries now if you have the option
to do
um
raw milk whole crane go with that it's
much healthier i've just released a
video on that and i will put that link
down below but if you mix whole cream
and blend that with berries it makes an
incredible dessert or you can make
whipping cream out of the whole cream
and add the berries you can also add
ghee and butter to your vegetables as
another way to decrease insulin
resistance another way to decrease
insulin resistance is to start
exercising exercise has been proven to
decrease insulin resistance and plus
you're burning off this extra sugar that
your liver is making from
gluconeogenesis
and i just want to mention this one
thing sometimes people eat because they
have low blood sugars well what do you
think is causing the low blood sugar
it's the high
insulin it's pushing your blood sugars
down and so when you eat that snack to
satisfy your low blood sugar
insulin kicks right in and
now you're back with low blood sugar
again it's a never ending
cycle
so the way you fix low blood sugars is
you cut out the carbs and you do what
i'm talking about right here now there's
other things you can do as well to speed
up the process vitamin b1
i like nutritional yeast as my source of
natural bee ones make sure it's not
fortified
potassium potassium is a really key
mineral to help with that chromium is
another mineral but it's a trace mineral
that can help with blood sugars zinc is
very very important
for the pancreas and the cells that make
insulin and then magnesium
and vitamin d
now i hope i increase your awareness on
the devastating consequences of snacking
but there's some more information to
know about
related to snacking and i put that up
right here check it out